Reeves with an early Flex for the fans during
the introductions out on the line with Noah
Gregor and David Camp DJ broy lost an edge Jake
Evans away Evans has a break Evans in stores Jake
Evans the ice breaker and his first goal in 18
games against seron here he takes advantage of
the opportunity Brody just gets himself all tied
up good effort by Gregor to try to close the gap
and even get maybe a little slash in that wasn't
going to be called but Evans just oblivious to
it all the one thing that Evans does have is
some great speed and watch him Focus early
on on keeping his legs moving pushing the puck
across and then from one side to the other but
you got to just use your strength for verzi get
skating get foreing and try to get them the pop
maybe an odd man Rush here for Montreal Kirby
Dock's got it slowski hont scores and Alex new
hook has his first goal as a Montreal Canadian
that's what Kowski does here though he makes
the play behind his own goal line and gets on his
horse and gets out from the play Doc doesn't have
winding speed but look at slum kosi that takes
kar's first split second kingberg is a little
late getting there he made the plate in the
other end defensively and then makes a head
of a back hand pass for an easy tap in for new
hook but doc with a nice reach around the stick
fosi reach around the stick to cber around it
comes to Kirby dock mat at the line the point
player product onto the right side for Doc down
low mahe it front confield scores power play
goal line it was so close but how about
this opening up the scam a little over
aggressive but what a read from down
low and pfield just shows his ability
to shoot from anywhere he gets this one
in tight into his feet it's a fluttering
Puck that doesn't matter for him he gets it
up and over it's Monahan coming across with
okay but oh does he get it back in time
after video review it's turn the play was
offside the 14 25 no [Applause] more
pass Harvey Bernard at Center Quick
Pass good one by mck over the line here comes
Gregor scores no Gregor has his first as a
m Greger jumps up the linesman gives a point
that it's okay A little hesitation to the
inside a delay to the outside and just
got it out moving a little bit too far
to his right Gregor with the quick release
in St got it to Matthews a elander off the
post first good look on this third power play now
martyr in front Matthew SCS hits number [Music]
300 that just gets the defense a little bit
settled back you can see the setup was there
just throw to the net and off John Taris in
front and right on the doorstep is Matthews
a reach back but look at where he shoots
that puck from from his back foot kingberg
over to Matthews in the final minute John
kingberg got it again Matthews Marner down
low it bounces to zarus Knocked away and KNE
Lander reloads gets it back scores a blast from
meander
a 40 goal season last year if you watched William
nander the one thing he's really been able to do
is power shots through from the longer range you
know sometimes you call a guy you go he can only
score from in tight one thing that last year IOD
KNE Lander really improved on look at him get down
on the one knee get the power on the bottom hand
and that one found a way to get right through the
arm to really make its mark an important power
play opportunity here for the Canadians to try
to tie things up it goes to Suzuki watched by
Camp back to mat seen past Coffield scores C
Field's got one that will stay on the board and
the game is tied so instead of forcing it right
away watch this little adjustment Brody comes
up now you move your feet and then you get a
lucky break right off the Stick of BR as he looks
Skyward but this play isn't possible without C
field recognized it's to get blocked the other way
puts it towards the net with all kinds of traffic
in front and samsonov never even saw that so the
second goal of the game fori but this one will be
the first that counts now the leaps go can't get
it out soosi came across to take it away back to
dock new hook trying to make himself available
instead it's Jacky scores aror Jacky and it was
tipped on rout and Alex new has Double Di great
athle athleticism by samsonov but it's doc again
who buys a little time with a rotation there's
the high tip by new hook you had both SLE posy
and new hook in that slot area haror Jacky with
his head up the whole way gets that one through
and gives NY some room twists and turns tried to
jam and it comes loose for Harvey penard to clear
now a turnover here's ping it in backand
scores a turnover and yes a Ulen gives
monreal a two goal lead TI you remember the
game's first goal it was Brody who lost his
balance here's a similar play whiffed on the
puck and then fell down and this is a tight
play but what patience with the puck here
ul and just no Panic whatsoever look at how
far samsonov tried to stretch himself across
you take a shot get the goenda up his power
play scored twice tonight and now six on five
something again that was practiced earlier in the
week net empty leaps need one to get within one
and tarus Matthew scores from a sh anle they
are within one nothing's really happening
you get an offensive zone face off a bold
decision and sometimes the simplest play
is the best one and here's one just rotate
from down low up to high Taris goes down and
you can see Allen wasn't expecting that shot
he didn't get his skate against the post
in a head up play by Matthews now saard
bumped along the boards trying to pin it
there Marner had it Loose Monahan spins KN
Lander set across El down scor it's a hatrick
on opening night and a game tire for Austin
Matthew seen so many times from Battle win the
puck in the corner and get it to the front of
the net first time not able to get control
but Matthew stays with it though you know
Chris this inability of Matthews to one time
this actually hurts Allen as he just flopped
across think Matthews was going to get the quick
shot how about the reaction though double clutch
got it around the stick in the glove and he ties
this game with a minute s that's toughing looking
Sam Sam went down there neander a post Coffield
a post Mitch Mar next man up scores and the leaps
have the shootout lead [Applause] You know despite
not having a whole lot of speed look at how deep
Allen is and how low he is and that's a read
there when you're moving the puck so quickly in
tight all you got to do is get it up and over the
glove and Marner able to deposit BBY dock got a
score and Samson on able to make the Stop and the
leaps come back for an opening night shot a win